Salut, pour ce nouveau Master Class on va parler encore du palais de mémoire.
Au mois de Mars dernier, dans la vidéo numéro 65,
Je vous parlais du Palais Mental,
Je vous présentais ça avec toutes les techniques de mémoire qu'on avait appris au préalable.
Vous pouviez associer l'ensemble dans un palais mental, un peu à la Sherlock.
Si vous n'avez pas vu cette vidéo, je vous invite à la regarder tout de suite
parce que ce Master Class est la suite logique du Palais Mental.
Au final vous l'avez compris il faut de l'ordre, de l'association et de la répétition.
L'ordre, c'est ce que vous avez dû faire depuis le mois de Mars en temps normal...Peut-être...
À partir d'aujourd'hui allez devoir vous entraîner un peu différemment
À chaque fois que vous vous baladez dans votre palais mental
Vous partez de départ pour aller jusqu'à l'arrivée
Ce qui serait intéressant maintenant
c'est que vous vous entraîniez
dans des ordres différents c'est à dire vous
propulser dans n'importe quelle pièce
ou dans n'importe quel endroit de votre palais
ou de commencer par la fin pour remonter au début.
pour le maîtriser un peu sous
toutes les formes sous toutes les coutures
Pour passer une étape maintenant dans
vos associations il va falloir
vous forcer absolument à jouer sur
l'émotion.
L'émotion dans la mémoire,
c'est soit quelque chose qui surprend
quelque chose qui peut faire rire
quelque chose de complètement atypique, de complètement hors propos
quelque chose qui fait peur pourquoi pas
C'est tout ce qui n'est pas logique
Tout ce qui a susciter un regard
différent de votre part et de votre conscient
Si je devais associer à un objet
courant comme un stylo
à un crochet de mémoire qui serai une main
je peux pas retenir que le crayon est
dans la main
ça n'a aucun intérêt en fait en
termes d'émotion par contre
si je commence à me transpercer la main
avec le stylo mentalement ou à me faire de
l'acupuncture avec plein de stylos sur le dos de la
main alors là c'est créer une émotion
en l'occurrence la douleur et c'est
certain que je vais le retenir
beaucoup plus efficacement.
Vos images doivent être extraordinaire, vous devez travailler
dans ce sens-là et elles vous viendront
toujours plus facilement, toujours plus
spontanément. Et la répétition c'est
un petit peu comme l'ordre une fois que
vous avez fourni votre palais mental
d'informations, continuez à vous balader
et d'aller voir ces informations d'aller les voir régulièrement,
pas forcément dans le même ordre mais pour bien les fixer dans son esprit il faut
continuer à se balader temps en temps
et c'est ça qui est formidable c'est
que à chaque temps faible de la
journée vous n'avez besoin de rien
d'autre que de votre esprit pour pouvoir le faire
La manière la plus classique je vous l'avais dit dans
la vidéo 65 d'utiliser le palais
mental
c'est pour retenir des listes de choses
des listes d'objets mais on peut retenir
des cours entiers on peut retenir des
discours entiers on peut retenir des
réunions de travail entières, si on
associe le palais mental avec le Mind Map
avec la carte mentale dont je vous parlais dans
la vidéo réussir ses examens puisque
la vraie clé de mémorisation c'est la
compréhension. Donc la carte mentale
va vous permettre de synthétiser des
choses de les comprendre globalement
complètement et de pouvoir faire un
schéma synthétique dans votre esprit
et c'est la première bulle de votre
carte mentale que vous allez pouvoir
associé à votre palais mental ce qui
fait qu'en vous baladant dans votre
palais mental quand vous allez tomber
sur cette bulle là vous allez avoir
toute la carte mentale qui va vous revenir
un petit peu comme une explosion et là
ça devient puissant de ouf
cette méthode est très efficace elle est pas
nouvelle elle a quasiment 3 000 ans
un petit peu moins. Les sénateurs romains s'en
servaient pour leurs discours, les grecs
avaient trouvé ça. L'histoire raconte
on sait pas si elle est vraie, que c'est
Simonide de Céos qui a trouvé
cette idée pour mémoriser.
Simonide était un poète grec c'est un des rares
poètes peut-être même le seul a
être rémunéré. D'après les écrits de
Cicéron c'est lui qui aurait inventé
la méthode des lieux qui est la base du palais mental. Un jour, Scopas qui
était un tyran commande un poème à Simonide.
Simonide écrit le poème, l'écrit
aussi bien qu'il le peut,
le livre à Scopas qui dit "tu
seras pas payé, tu seras payé que la
moitié parce que, dans ton poème à un
moment donné tu parles trop de Castor
et Pollux alors que le poème devait m'être dédié donc
je te paie la moitié l'autre moitié tu la demanderas aux dieux".
Et là-dessus il l'invite à manger
sûrement pour reciter le poème à
un moment donné. Lors du repas
Simonide est appelé à l'extérieur où il y a deux
personnes qui l'attendent et il doit
absolument aller à l'extérieur donc
il se libère de la table, il va dehors et au
moment où il va dehors le palais s'effondre
sur tous les invités et Simonide
comprends que les deux personnes qui
l'attendaient dehors sont Castor et
Pollux dont il avait écrit
sur la moitié du poème leurs louanges.
Le problème au-delà que
c'est une hécatombe sous le palais
c'est que comme le palais s'est effondré
les familles ne savent pas où chercher
les corps ne savent même pas des fois
les reconnaître cherche des objets et
des gens précis
et c'est là que Simonide dit "mais moi je sais où est tout mais moi je sais qui et qui
je sais où les choses sont placées
puisque j'étais assis j'ai juste à
fermer les yeux et à me remémorer
et tout va me revenir au fur et à mesure"
et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont retrouvé
les corps et que Simonide pouvait
donner l'identité de toutes les
personnes
C'est de là que serait née l'idée en tout cas de la méthode des lieux
et du palais mental.
J'espère que ce
nouveau Master Class sur le sujet vous aura
plu. Je vais commencer à faire des suites de ce
qui a été fait par exemple la semaine
prochaine vous tease un peu le prochain
Master Class sera la suite sur le
Cold reading et ça je sais que ça
vous intéresse
Cette vidéo est sortie un petit peu à
la bourre aujourd'hui en temps normal le samedi
c'est à 11 heures  aujourd'hui elle doit
sortir surement vers 11h40 / Midi
parce qu'il est exactement 11 heures.
J'ai eu un problème avec ma carte SD et
comme j'ai pas de matériel d'avance
mais je le note... Un grand merci spécial à tous ceux qui font les sous-titres
des vidéos c'est vrai que je parle pas
souvent de vous Ludivine ya plein
d'autres personnes. Enfin... "il y a pleins d'autres
personnes", non vous êtes assez peu
nombreux et nombreuses à le
faire vous en faites beaucoup donc
merci beaucoup ça ouvre toutes les
vidéos aux malentendants et ça c'est
grâce à vous et je vous félicite de ça
Si vous voulez que cette vidéo atteigne les étoiles n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce
qui vise, lui vers la lune vous pouvez
également laisser un commentaire au bas de la
vidéo, vous abonner à la chaîne parce
que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez-vous demain à
11 heures
Tchao !